yes
to put a bit more spin oh that's good
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
this is intense I don't want to lose
this
[Applause]
probably my best roller ever
[Applause]
all right
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
it stayed
oh
wow
[Applause]
oh no
that was a roller
[Applause]
foreign
try this one moving Target
okay
oh
okay okay
whoa
that took a while
come on
give me your hardest Loop
oh it is it was so fast you couldn't see
it
[Music]
you to hit subscribe
[Music]
[Applause]
again
[Music]
spin move
boy
oh you got it through
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh nice
oh you got it
oh
you nice
good one
the margins are pretty slim
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh you got it
and duh
TWA
Katra
sang get saved
this is so
sit
down
[Applause]
[Applause]
what
along the wall nobody noticed anything
oh
sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
we got it
yes
one two three one two three four one two
three four five one two three four five
six one two three four five six seven
one two three
but we got seven seven
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
we're trying to get this channel to 5
million subscribers so if you haven't
subscribed yet please help us out and do
it now